حجم صغير نسبيا لكنها قادره على قتل
مخلوقات اكبر منها بكثير
ضحاياها من الحيوانات بالالاف وقطره واحده
من سمها تعني النهايه لبعض البشر وربما
بدايه حياه جديده لاخرين
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
هذه عنكبوت الارمله السوداء نراها هنا قد
اصطادت فريستها واي فريسه ثعبان حجمه اكبر
بعشرين ضعفا من حجمها وليس هذا فحسب بل
انها تقتل زوجها بعد التزاوج وهي مصنفه
ضمن العشر الاوائل في عالم العناكب من حيث
قوه سمها فهو اشد فتكا واقوى بخمسه عشره
مره من سم الافاعي ينتقل عبر الاوعيه
الدمويه ويصيب الاجهزه العصبيه وقد يقتل
كبار السن او الاطفال الصغار ذوي المناعه
الضعيفه في حال لم ياخذ العقار المضاد في
الوقت المناسب اما عن هذا العنكبوت
فالارمله السوداء امامه ربما تكون اكثر
رحمه انه العنكبوت البرازيلي المتجول شكله
كبير ولونه بني ويشبه عنكبوت الذئب في
امريكا الشماليه ولكنه اكبر ويمتلك سما
اكثر خطوره وهو الاول في تصنيف العناكب
السامه ولحسن الحظ تم تطوير عقار مضاد
لسمه عام 1996
حالات التعرض للادغات العنكبوت البرازيلي
شائعه جدا يحتوي السمبو على عدد من
المركبات الناشطه بما في ذلك الهيستامين
والسيروتونين بالاضافه الى السم العصبي
لدغته مؤلمه للغايه وتسبب عددا من الاعراض
مثل سيلان اللعاب والتعرق والتشنجات
العضليه ومشاكل بصريه وعاده ما تحدث وفيات
بسبب فشل الجهاز التنفسي
في المرتبه الاولى من حيث السميه ياتي
العنكبوت البرازيلي فقد صنف سموه بحسب
موسوعه غينيس على انه اقوى بعشرين مره من
الارمله السوداء التي تاتي ثانيا في
الترتيب ويليها عنكبوت الخضر نقي المقيد
ثم الارمله السوداء البنيه والعنكبوت
المتشرد اما في المرتبه السادسه فياتي
عنكبوت الناس كل البني
لكن ورغم خطوره تلك المخلوقات استطاع
العلماء استغلال مركبات في سمها لتطوير
علاجات لامراض ارقت البشر وفتكت بارواح
الالاف عبر التاريخ
دراسه قادها باحثون في معهد فيكتور
تشانجلي ابحاث القلب في سيدني باستراليا
كشفت ان سم العنكبوت القمعيه الوتراء يمكن
ان يستخدم لمساعده ضحايا النوبات القلبيه
على التعافي واطاله عمر القلوب المستخدمه
في عمليات الزرع الدراسه اكدت ان العقار
المستخلص من سم هذا العنكبوت يعمل عن طريق
ايقاف اشاره الموت المرسله من القلب في
اعقاب النوبه القلبيه
لن يساعد هذا فقط مئات الالاف من الذين
يصابون بنوبه قلبيه كل عام في جميع انحاء
العالم بل يمكن ان يزيد ايضا عدد ونوعيه
قلوب المتبرعين ما يمنح الامل لمن ينتظرون
في قائمه الزرع
ولكل ما لديهم رهاب من العناكب اليكم هذه
المعلومه التي ربما تكون مزعجه بعض الشيء
العلماء قدروا وجود نحو 43 الف نوع مختلف
معروف من العناكب لكن الصدمه انه يوجد على
كوكبنا الكثير من الانواع الاخرى التي لم
يتم اكتشافها بعد